- You know it's cause it's a bad thing
to even say that I have no
respect for females man.
You know what I'm saying?
That's formed from my upbringing.
You know, I believe that my
mama played a big part in
who I am today, you know what I'm saying?
I believe that she could
have done something to
prevent all the shit
that I've been through.
You know what I'm saying?
If she would just said,
"Fuck it, I'm gone."
Ya Know what I'm saying?
But no, she stayed.
- [Mark] Bruce uh, Bruce,
where'd you grow up?
- Um, I was born and raised in California.
I mainly grew up in the
city of Los Angeles.
- [Mark] And you grew up
with both your parents?
- I grew up with a parent and a half.
- [Mark] What do you mean
by a parent and a half?
- Well, my mother, she
was very, what I say,
um "you love and I say love you"
You know what I'm
saying, whatever that is.
And my dad, he was a beast.
He was a monster.
You know so he wasn't a parent
he was a monster you know.
- [Mark] In what way?
- Well you know he would use his fist
I mean to beat the kids,
you know beat us up.
You know what I am saying.
Then he'd go out sometimes, get drunk,
come back two or three or
four o'clock in the morning,
start in on my mama you
know what I'm staying
and we would have to leave the house
at whatever time it was
between those hours.
You know what I'm saying.
And my mother did not drive
at the time, you know?
And she had six of the kids
she had to pull along with her
and we have to get in the streets
and walk just to get away from him.
You know love was not a word
that was spoken in my household
you know what I guess.
Because my parents didn't
know what love was.
You know what I'm saying.
And so the only language that you know,
I can recall is you are a lie bitch, hoe.
The crazy stuff I says crazy stuff.
You know, sounded funny, another word.
I'm just gonna say crazy. You know.
And, and both of my
parents were from Arkansas.
You know what I'm saying.
One from Palm Bluff and
one from Little Rock.
and
My father's side was more,
leaned more towards the country
and my mother was more
like a city girl. You know.
But you know, even
I guess when my father worked growing up
the same kind of stuff was
going on in his household.
You know what I'm saying.
You know, my, my family,
they fight, shoot, whatever
You know, my, my family, they
fight, shoot, whatever to
each other have sex with each
other and all of crazy stuff.
You know what I'm saying.
I got a crazy family
you know. Crazy family
I mean, sometimes my
dad would beat my mama
and I could hardly recognize her
she was like the elephant woman
because I don't think you know
he broke her arm one time.
You know, he didn't, he
didn't, he didn't hold no
He didn't pull no strength back, you know?
And I guess it kinda like
killed my respect for females.
You know what I'm saying?
And I guess, because I believe
that my mom didn't even stand
up. You know what I'm saying.
So yeah it.
I believe I can't trust a female.
You know what I'm saying?
And you know, that's
just how it is you know
and
heh
and its cold because
if I can't trust a female,
who can I give myself to
You know what I'm saying.
And get someone in return?
You know? So you go through life,
feeling alone, you know what I'm saying.
So its, you know my childhood
it really fucked me up,
you know. The beast
that my mother suffered,
you know what I'm saying.
and how she can choose to let it go on.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
I said how she continues let it go on.
You know, and that's where,
you know, my animosity
or my fuel of betrayal comes in
because it continues to go on and on
you know, and me as a kid you know
I was thinking of things that can be done,
you know what I'm saying? Like.
Yeah. I mean, no um, on two occasions
my father had beaten my momma up
and so, I'm under the illusion,
I'm under the belief that she
was fed up, she was tired,
You know what I'm saying.
Because you know, I
went wherever she went,
you know, and so me and her
went to the pawn shop to get a gun.
We bought a gun, she bought a gun.
You know, and you know me as
a kid and who I was feeling
I was filled with joy, I was,
(Motorcycle's riding by)
I was mean, I was ready, you know.
I'm thinking were going
to ki. get rid of him,
You know what I'm saying.
And on both occasions so kind of way,
my momma let my daddy get the gun.
you know what I'm saying.
I mean, you know, he woke me up one time
at three o'clock with a
fucking butcher knife.
You know what I'm saying.
And they used to always say,
I bring you into this would
and I take you out, you
know what I'm saying?
So, that's got to be frightened
to a kid, man come on,
when you hear that I
brought you into this world
and I'll take you out out numerous time,
repeatedly, then you know,
to be woke up four o'clock
with a drunk man with a butcher
knife standing over you.
Come on I mean.
And you know, I mean,
I just I blame my mama,
you know what I'm saying.
I blame my mama and I blame me, you know.
For being a kid that couldn't
do anything about it.
you know and so you know and those scars,
I just believe that they
never go away, you know.
They imbedded in me, you
know what I'm saying.
- [Mark] You feel your-
- I'm a mothers child, I'm a mothers boy.
- [Mark] You feel like
your mom left it happen?
- I feel like she continued
to let it go on, yes. Yes.
You know and being a kid.
You know I told myself, I promised myself
that I would never be like my daddy.
You know. Heh, you know what though,
I ended up to be just like him.
- [Mark] What are the personality traits
you need to be a pimp?
- Aggressiveness, no regard
and selfishness. That's it.
- What are, what are the
personality traits a girl needs
to work for a pimp?
- Insecure, Low self-esteem and desire.
Desire to be something more than she is.
You know what I'm saying.
And she has to have trust,
she has to have trust that
I am going to be the one to bring her
from where she at to where she want to go.
so yeah, yeah, hmm yeah.
- They bring their money to you
and you take care of
them with clothes and,
- No.
- Food and stuff like that.
- No, they bring their money
to me and I take care of me.
That's it you know.
Other pimps might buy'em clothes and shit,
you know what I'm saying, not me.
You know whatever I do,
that's what they go to do,
wherever I stay, that
where they got to stay.
You know what I'm saying.
So I don't provide them
with no luxurious house
or none of that bullshit, no.
- [Bruce] Here it is I'm 60 years old.
And of those 60 years
is for public record.
You know if you go back,
I can guarantee you
that I've probably done at least
25 of those years in prison,
you know what I'm saying.
I did all my 30s, I went to jail,
I went to prison I had an 18
year sentence in 1992 thank god
you know because soon after
that they had that riot
and I believed that if
I'd have been there,
it would've been terrible.
But every minute of my
thirties, I spent in prison.
You know started at Pelican Bay.
You know, it's supposed to be I guess
the hardest prison in
the state of California.
I loved the pelican bay, I did.
To me Pelican bay was the
best prison I ever went to.
Yeah and I've been to a host of them.
I got out of jail was 41 years old.
I went when I was 29.
I got out when I was 41, so.
All those middle days and
years was spent in prison,
Every minute of it.
- What were your 18 years for?
- (mumbles) You don't want to know.
Um, I got that sentence for
a host of real bad things.
You know what I'm saying.
ADW's, Mayhem's, robbery's, you know
that's the kind of stuff I used to do.
You know what I'm saying.
I was hurt so bad as a kid emotionally
and physically I'll say.
I told myself, you know, if I felt pain,
someone else is gonna feel it to.
You know and hmm its
still a rule to this day.
You know what I'm saying.
Unfortunately, you know,
I take a little bit more
than I normally take,
but if I feel like you wanna
inflict some pain on me,
I'm gonna inflict some on you.
But (indistinct) anyway I don't care.
Men you know as you know I
say I don't respect women.
Women don't make a, to me
it don't make a difference.
You know what I'm saying.
I don't want nobody to
be like me, you know
and don't think that I
don't have a son man.
You know what I'm saying.
I have a daughter born and she's
just like me. That's crazy.
Thank you for allowing me to share.